Diego had only just found his footing when
it gave out underneath him again.
Crashing to the ground, he threw both arms
over his head just in time to protect his
skull from the rain of boulders that came
down past him.
They grazed his arms and jarred painfully
against his muscles, but it was better than
having them hit him in the head.
Without a moment to spare, Diego got straight
up to his feet and continued running back
down the trail he had been trying to follow.
The ground shifted and lurched in all directions
under him, threatening to throw off his balance
at any moment.
Having lived in Chile his whole life, he had
gotten used to earthquakes, but he had never
been in the center of one like this.
The problem was that the trail he had been
following to get up here was disappearing
fast as the dust swirled into the air and
boulders landed all around him.
He just had to keep running in this direction
and hope for the best.
There weren't any other options.
But suddenly, he found himself running uphill.
Stumbling forwards, Diego tried desperately
to get his bearings.
He had spent the previous three hours hiking
up the mountains, so how was it that now that
he had turned around and gone back, he was
still going uphill?
It was almost as if the ground was changing
shape beneath him as he ran.
Dust filled his lungs as he tried to wipe
it away from his burning eyes.
Yes, the ground was definitely going uphill,
but it felt almost as if it was lifting itself
up beneath him, as if some tectonic plates
were grinding together, creating a new mountain
beneath his feet.
Diego lurched unsteadily and grabbed the nearest
rock to keep his balance, feeling the ground
lifting higher and higher beneath him.
Then, all of a sudden, the cloud of dust broke,
and he was in fresh air rising ever higher
into the sky.
The Andes mountains stabbed out of the clouds
all around him, cutting beautiful shapes across
the horizon.
He felt his own mountain steadily growing
taller than any of them.
He dropped down on all fours and clutched
at the ground in terror as he tried his best
to take in the shape of what he was now standing
upon.
*
How far would you go to prevent a cosmic-level
disaster?
It's one thing to save your friends and family
from an armed murderer; it's another thing
to fight for your country in a world war.
We can even just about imagine what it means
to fight for our planet, to save our species
from climate change, to save our world from
a meteorite.
But what would a cosmic disaster look like?
A calamity so broad in scale that it surpasses
our ability to even perceive the threat.
We could point our most advanced telescope
into deep space and look straight down the
middle of it, and never know it's even there.
And if that threat was not simply to the survival
of humanity or planet Earth but to the survival
of existence itself, how far would we go to
prevent it?
What cruel and inhumane measures would you
take to have such a threat?
How many people would you kill to save the
world?
This debate is raging right now as you sit
here and watch this video, not among the Foundation
but between two SCPs so grand in scale and
so advanced in nature that the Foundation
has no option but to sit and listen as the
pair debate what to do with the human race.
SCP-4568-1 was not difficult to discover once
it started moving.
In fact, it was almost impossible to ignore.
Earthquakes have been tearing across South
America for centuries, destroying homes, taking
the lives of innocent people, and fundamentally
changing the shape of our planet itself.
What most people do not realize, however,
is that the fault line running through the
Andes mountain range has actually largely
been dormant during this period.
The source of the earthquakes has come from
something far more mysterious.
Our innocent hiker, Diego, had been spending
the week walking among the Andes when the
earthquake struck.
You would be forgiven for assuming, as Diego
did, that the ground rising beneath his feet
was a new mountain forming as the tectonic
plates crashed together.
But the staggering reality of the situation
was that he found himself hiking along the
back of SCP-4568-1.
As the creature raised its head into the air,
Diego saw the head of a serpent lifting several
kilometers away from him.
Its body stretched and wound its way through
the mountain range, filling the valleys and
running beneath his feet.
The scale of SCP-4568-1 is hard to convey.
Measuring over 500 kilometers in length, this
serpent is longer than most US states, with
a 20 km width.
Standing on the back of it quite literally
feels like standing on a mountain range.
For context, the horizon at sea level is about
4.8 kilometers away, so multiply that by 4,
and you’ll get a sense of just how wide
this thing is.
Even small movements from this SCP are enough
to trigger continent-wide earthquakes, with
tremors being felt all the way around the
world.
Upon the initial discovery of this SCP, the
Foundation was unable to determine why it
remains dormant for such long periods and
seems to only awaken sporadically and for
brief periods of time.
That was, until SCP-4568-2 was discovered.
It is little wonder that the second serpent
took so long to be found.
Its body is composed almost entirely of water,
sand, algae, and steam.
It does not show up on sonar scans and is
incredibly difficult to detect in the water,
even visually.
Its form is loosely defined whilst dormant.
With broadly similar measurements to SCP-4568-1,
this serpent roams the South Pacific Ocean.
Any marine creatures that swim into the SCP's
body find themselves undergoing beneficial
mutations.
Crabs grow extra pincers, bottom feeders grow
larger mouths, and sharks find themselves
developing heightened senses and even extra
hearts.
These marine animals seem to undergo virtually
no distress and are free to exit and re-enter
the SCP's body at any point.
Initially, SCP-4568-2 was believed to be the
peaceful one of the pair.
Both serpents seemed to become active at the
same time.
While on land, SCP-4568-1 would wreak havoc
with magnitude 7 earthquakes in major metropolitan
areas, the sea serpent's function was less
well understood.
Employing resonant frequencies and vibrations,
this SCP was able to give its watery body
a distinct form as it rose up from the ocean
and towered above the waves.
In order to maintain its shape and control
its movements, this SCP employed a huge amount
of energy.
However, the Foundation quickly observed that
it was rarely able to maintain its form for
very long.
As soon as the sea serpent rose out of the
water, its mountainous twin would begin to
move, sending tremors around the world that
disrupted the frequency needed for SCP-4568-2
to remain animate.
Exhausted and unable to maintain its shape,
the sea serpent would fall into another period
of dormancy, gliding lazily through the oceans.
But this dormancy suited the Foundation.
Without the constant seismic tremors, researchers
could work fast.
Two operating bases were set up to monitor
each SCP.
Two mirrored bases with mirrored teams in
constant communication with one another.
As soon as one team made a discovery, it was
conveyed to the others and vice versa.
One operating base was set up high in the
Andes mountains, specifically designed to
be as earthquake-proof as possible, capable
of withstanding earthquakes of up to 9.9 magnitude.
Meanwhile, in the South Pacific Ocean, an
underwater research center was built just
above the seabed, with regular vessels drifting
out into the unknown to gather whatever data
they could about the great SCPs.
Several early findings stood out.
Firstly, SCP-4568-1 appeared to have a very
different internal structure from its twin.
Researchers initially assumed that the creature
would be largely composed of earth minerals
and rock, as its exterior appearance suggested.
However, scans of its body indicated the presence
of what can only be assumed to be artificially
created components.
Great gears resembling clockwork structures
and even rudimentary circuitry were present
throughout the creature's body.
The function or origin of these gears has
yet to be determined, especially as there
is no evident way that their movement corresponds
to the autonomy and movement of the serpent
itself.
The far more striking discovery, however,
came when the SCP Foundation discovered a
way to communicate with the two beasts.
Ultra-low-frequency waves capable of traveling
vast distances, even light years, were discovered
to be emitted from the two serpents' heads
at intermittent periods.
The Foundation had to develop some of the
largest antennas ever created to pick up these
frequencies and interpret the data coming
through them.
What they found were two twins locked in a
fierce debate about the fate of humanity and
the universe itself.
It was only then that the motivations of these
two serpents started to make sense.
In 2010, almost as soon as the Foundation
was able to tap into the frequency, they were
contacted directly by SCP-4568-1.
"Fundacion, I know you can now hear me.
I will not apologize for my actions.
I know that I am the reason that millions
of your kind face their demise.
I know your pain and I feel it too.
But I shall never apologize for it.
I simply ask you to listen to myself and to
my [word cannot be translated].
You are curious, you can be patient.
Exercise that and you may one day understand."
And listen, the Foundation did.
Efforts to contain or destroy the two serpents
were put on the back burner.
Instead, Foundation agents prioritized spreading
disinformation across South America and beyond
about the source of these earthquakes.
The two serpents are far too large and far
too powerful to overcome or contain.
Instead, the Foundation prioritized the use
of amnestic drugs, disinformation, and the
creation of fringe conspiracy groups to discredit
any claims of the serpents' respective existences.
Meanwhile, some of the most senior leadership
figures in the Foundation were and still are
locked in a fierce debate as to what to do
with the twin serpents.
By listening to the communications between
the two SCPs, the Foundation discovered that
SCP-4568-2 is intent on wiping out the entire
human race.
The only thing that has prevented it from
being able to do so thus far has been the
existence of the other serpent.
Every time that SCP-4568-2 begins to mount
an attack on humanity, its land-bearing twin
triggers enormous earthquakes to disrupt its
progress.
But why would the sea serpent want to destroy
the human race?
As Foundation generals gathered in the deep
sea operations base, SCP-4568-2 came to the
observation window to look them in the eyes
as it told them:
"I am sure you can see it.
How your world dies a little bit more every
day.
Mostly by your own hand, no?
You poison the oceans, taint the rivers, blacken
the skies.
You do not need angels of death to destroy
your world.
But there is something else.
I see it, in the bottom of your eyes: something
unforgettable.
Unconceivable ideas, cloaked in madness and
impossible colors.
Do you think I will let you drag the rest
of the world down with yourselves?
Do you think I will leave this world, my world,
to die in flames?
It sees your world, and it comes in fives."
Since this revelation, the Foundation has
poured countless hours and resources into
trying to identify a cosmic threat.
For well over a decade, many of the smartest
scientists the world has to offer have looked
to the night sky, scanning for this impossible
color, this shroud of madness, but to no avail.
Some within the Foundation believe the Serpent
is lying, trying to make up an excuse to justify
its genocide, but information from SCP-4568-1
seems to confirm everyone's worst fears.
"Your minds burn bright, Fundacion.
All of humanity shines from this rock like
a candle in a dark room.
It sees you.
An idea exists only because something thought
of it.
Have you even considered how such terrible
concepts could have been given form?
What kind of atrocious mind could even think
about it?
Humans cannot conceive the colorless green.
What if you are playing into this creature's
hands?"
There appears to be an underlying implication
that ideas are the source of power somehow.
This colorless green, this unimaginable cosmic
threat, seems to be a monstrous idea incarnate.
But whose idea?
Humanity’s?
There is a deep lore that the two serpents
discuss with one another, one that makes little
sense even to this day to the Foundation.
They talk of gods and goddesses, deities of
flesh, of steel and gears, and of ‘the fives’.
Quite what these creatures are, if they are
even creatures at all, is a mystery to the
Foundation.
Researchers have not discovered a way of communicating
back with the two serpents directly.
Attempts to mimic their language or transmit
signals asking questions to them have been
largely ignored.
Instead, they address humanity and the Foundation
as a whole, seeming to take the view of the
human race as being a collective hive of mind,
one that they are evidently able to tap into.
The pair seem uninterested in informing us
as to exactly what this threat is or explaining
who the gods and goddesses are.
Perhaps they assume we know these things already,
or more likely, they believe that our consciousness
is not yet capable of perceiving the scale
and depth of the concepts they are debating.
What is clear, however, is their shared understanding
that if humanity were to be eliminated, the
candle was to be blown out, this cosmic threat
would pass by.
The pair have names.
Trentrén is the land serpent, while remaining
dormant much of the time in an enormous cave
system beneath the Andes Mountains.
This serpent seems keen to help the Foundation
in some way.
Kaikai, the sea serpent, is intent on sacrificing
the human race for a greater good, one far
beyond our understanding.
Speaking to the Foundation in the Andes Mountains,
Trentrén gave a short speech that served
both as encouragement and a terrible warning
of the darkness to come.
"It is something I like about you, Fundación.
About mankind.
While it is easy to just take the simplest
path, to just give up, there will always be
some among you who refuse this path, who do
the right thing.
Maybe not all of you are this strong, but
I can see it in your methods, those so-called
'containment procedures.'
There will always be someone who stands up
against the dark, even if it takes a thousand
million years to emerge victorious.
Maybe you can stop the Fifth.
After all, ideas can be killed with better
ideas."
Even if it takes a thousand million years…
Now go check out “SCP-2317 - The Devourer
of Worlds / A Door to Another World” and
“SCP-001 - The World's Gone Beautiful!”